a new era
a little miracle of technology the
atomic power stations are going up we're
bombarded with radiation all the time
from everyday objects like
a watch most people think that
radioactive waste is some kind of
glowing green goo
but in actual fact it looks a little bit
like this black glass
it will be radioactive for hundreds of
thousands of years
and this is why we really need to think
about its long-term future
the danger of radioactive waste is here
today and goes on and on tomorrow
in full operation it will supply
electricity
for a million people climate change the
gases blamed for global warming are
pumped out in ever bigger quantities
the window of time to mitigate the
climate crisis is shrinking
by the day really the problem is how to
reduce greenhouse gases
nuclear power has a long proven record
as a non-fossil energy source nuclear
energy
is not a solution to climate change
[Music]
nuclear energy has a fraught history
greeted with optimism in the 1950s
its reputation was clouded by atomic
bomb tests and disasters like chernobyl
but as global leaders work to tackle
climate change nuclear power's allure
has come
full circle once up and running nuclear
power stations emit no carbon dioxide
or other greenhouse gases and nuclear's
constant energy generation
sets it apart from renewable sources of
energy whose output can vary
for the past 60 years or so it has
provided a very important
type of electricity which we call base
load power
that's the type of electricity that
guarantees that
24 7 no matter when you want to flip on
or off your light switch
the lights will be there the inherent
dangers of nuclear energy
make it a controversial energy source
and not everyone agrees it's worth the
risks it brings
nearly all of our nuclear waste is at
coastal sites in one way
or the other these are locations that
are liable to
coastal processes storm surges sea level
rise
those are highly vulnerable to the worst
impacts of climate change that we can
foresee
i'm concerned about the dangers it poses
accidents can happen and will happen
in 2011 a devastating earthquake and
tsunami in japan
led to meltdown at the fukushima daiichi
nuclear reactor
as a result of the fukushima accident
both japan
and germany for different reasons they
decided to shut down rapidly
their national nuclear energy output
they ramped up coal and gas
output uh for a few years after the
accident
dr korecha's research found that there
were health consequences linked to this
reduction in the use of nuclear energy
as both countries increased their use of
fossil fuels in subsequent years
as a direct yet unintended consequence
of their decision
to drastically reduce their nuclear
power output
after the fukushima accident both japan
and germany together
lost the opportunity to prevent over 28
000
air pollution-induced premature deaths
that were as a result of fossil fuel
power use
japan is slowly restoring its nuclear
capacity while germany has increased its
renewable energy output over the past
decade
although that was accompanied by a steep
rise in energy prices for the public
for countries with nuclear in their
energy mix such as the uk
finland and china constructing efficient
new reactors is both expensive
and time consuming hinckley point c
britain's first nuclear reactor since
1995
will cost 23 billion pounds at least
twice as much as the london 2012 olympic
games
and this figure continues to rise
modern nuclear reactors are designed
meticulously and built to withstand
earthquakes and other threats
including plane crashes but even the
best designed nuclear reactors create
radioactive waste
and that needs careful disposal in the
uk
we have about four and a half million
cubic metres of radioactive waste
the largest portion of this about 96 is
low-level waste
high-level waste is very high
radioactivity material but we have the
smallest volume of this
just less than one percent the radiation
from high-level waste is so intense that
if you were to touch it you'd receive a
radiation dose about a million times
more than you would receive throughout
an entire year just from natural
radiation sources
it's extremely high for several
thousands even hundreds of thousands of
years
so ideally where we want to be is in a
place where we can isolate those wastes
from future populations
in a safe way for example digging a very
deep hole underground
and disposing of the waste there forever
this solution is known as a geological
disposal facility
where waste is disposed of between 200
and 1000 meters below the earth's
surface
because most people don't like the idea
of living next to radioactive waste
it's been very difficult for governments
to find a suitable site
let alone start building one finland is
currently the only country in the world
building a permanent underground storage
facility for their nuclear waste
every nation with nuclear power has so
far stored its waste in temporary
facilities
and those facilities are aging
i'm not against deep disposal because i
think ultimately
we'll have to deal with our present
waste that way
but that is so far ahead that the
problem here and now
is safe storage and all the time we're
waiting for the holy grail
of a deep disposal facility the job of
that facility
is to deal with the massive amounts of
nuclear waste that we already have the
idea that we should be
piling more and unknown quantities for
far
further ahead is absolutely uh
ludicrous in my view if we don't get our
hands on clean energy and
rapidly scale them up by as much as
possible
within the next few decades then we're
leaving a massive massive
burden on future generations we need to
completely decarbonize the electricity
sector
and ideally also the overall energy
sector if we're to avert the worst
impacts of the human-caused climate
crisis as our understanding of the
climate crisis deepens
and energy demands continue to grow the
necessity that our energy comes from
non-fossil fuel sources
makes nuclear power hard to ignore it is
expensive and it can be dangerous if
safety protocols are not followed
the highly radioactive waste it
generates is hugely challenging to store
safely
but it also provides a reliable power
baseline
keeping the lights from turning off on a
cloudy windless winter evening
and meeting country's energy needs as
they transition away
from fossil fuels and that
is the nuclear dilemma
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification
each time we upload a new video